I willat of your
conf moderating this press conference
we'll have a few questions in the room
uh we'll have first few remarks from the
the speakers and then a questions from
the room and then we'll go on Zoom so
you can please feel free to use the
raise hand function at point during this
press conference so I can hand you the
mic
afterwards at any moment during the
Press confence so that I be able to give
you the floor during question
stage Supra Sharma from Health Canada Dr
M ber the S Canada Dr
teres from the public health agency of
Canada Howard
new you Tunis National advisory
committee on
immunization on that doctors you have
the floor and we'll go to the question
period
after thank you mer uh good morning
thank you for joining us today before I
begin I just like to acknowledge that
Canada is the homeland of First Nations
Inu and matey people and that we are
gathering in Ottawa on the unseated
traditional territory of the alanka and
alavia people today I'm today I'm here
to talk to you about health Canada's
authorization of the new madna BX
Co 19 vaccine targeting the Omron xbb
1.5 subvariant we have authorized this
vaccine for people 6 months of age and
older the vaccine was authorized after
an independent and thorough scientific
review for safety efficacy and quality
and this included a review of data from
several studies of the primary series
and booster doses of the vax
vaccine collected over the past two
years after assessing all the data we've
concluded that there is strong evidence
showing that the benefits of this
vaccine outweigh the potential risks
individuals who are 5 years of age and
older should receive one dose of the
vaccine regardless of their coid 19
vaccination history and children between
6 months and four years of age should
receive two doses if they have not
previously been vaccinated with a CO 19
vaccine and if they have been previously
vaccinated with one or more doses they
should receive a single dose this
vaccine is anticipated to provide a
robust immune response that will be
effective against the Omicron xbb
1.1 variant Health Canada is also
actively reviewing submissions from
fiser biotch and novavax seeking
authorization of the respective xpb 1.5
coid 19 vaccines these submissions are
being reviewed on a priority basis by
dedicated scientific
teams timing for the completion of these
reviews depends on many factors we will
make decisions once we have thoroughly
evaluated ated all of the required
information Health Canada continues to
use rigorous and independent scientific
processes to ensure all Health Products
meet our stringent requirements for
safety efficacy and quality before
allowing them on the
market and as with all of Health
candidates vaccine and Drug
authorizations we want to stress that we
only examine the most robust scientific
evidence from trusted and reliable
sources we recognize that there's an
abundance of information available
that's sometimes false and exaggerated
we encourage people to consider their
sources of information very
carefully as we did with all our Co 19
vaccines we're publishing a number of
documents about this decision including
the Canadian product monograph and the
regulatory decision summary which
provides a high level summary of the
evidence that we reviewed all of this
information is available on the
government of Canada's main Co 19
website Health Canada and the public
health agency of Canada will monitor for
any Adverse Events in collaboration with
the provinces and territories
International partners and and
manufacturers as with all vaccines we
will take action if any new safety
issues are
identified today's authorization
provides people in Canada with more
protection against Co 19 I know we all
wish Co 19 no longer existed but people
are still getting infected and
vaccination continues to be one of the
most effective ways to protect ourselves
against serious outcomes including
severe illness hospitalization and death
vaccine protection decreases over time
which means many of us are due for
another dose receiving a shot of the new
formulation will help protect people
against the variant circulating
currently and expected to circulate
through the fall and winter thank you
Mercy
Mig good morning thank you for joining
us
today before I begin I would like to
acknowledge that Canada is the homeland
of First Nations in and people and that
we are gathering in Ottawa on the
unseated traditional territory of the
Alan people today I'm here to talk to
you about health Canada's authorization
of the new
modid 19 vaccine targeting the Omron
xbb
1.5 we have authorized this
vaccine six months of age and older the
vaccine was authorized after an
independent and thorough scientific
review for safety efficacy and quality
this included a review of data from
several studies of the primary series
and booster doses of the fact
vaccine collected over the past two
years after assessing all the data we
have concluded that there is strong
evidence showing that the benefits of
this vaccine outweigh the potential risk
indiv individuals who are five years ofe
and older should receive one dose of the
vaccine regardless of their Co
vaccination history children between 6
months and four years of age should
receive two doses if they not previously
been vaccinated with a vaccine if they
have been previously vaccinated with one
or more doses they should receive a
single dose this vaccine is anticipated
to provide a robust immune response that
will be effective against the
AR variant Canada is also actively
reviewing submissions from fer bio inch
and Novac seeking authorization of their
respective
xbb vac these submissions are being
reviewed on a priority basis by
dedicated
timing for the completion of the these
reviews depends on many factors we will
make decisions once we have thoroughly
evaluated all of the required
information Health Canada continues to
use a rigorous and independent
scientific process to ensure all Health
Products need our stringent requirements
for safety efficacy and quality before
allowing them on the
market as with all of Health Canada's
vaccine and Drug authorizations we want
to stress that we only examine the most
robust scientific evidence from trusted
and reliable
sources we recognize that there is an
abundance of information available is
sometimes false and exaggerated we
encourage people to consider their
sources of information
carefully as we did with all of other Co
19 vaccines we are publishing a number
of documents about this decision
including the Canadian product monograph
and the regulatory decision summary
which provides a high level summary of
the evidence that we all of this
information is available on the
government of Canada's main 19
website Canada and the public health
agency of Canada will monitor for any
Adverse
Events and this in collaboration with
the provinces and territories
International partners and the
manufactur as with all vaccines we will
take action if any new safety issues are
identified today's authorization
provides people in Canada with more prot
against I know we all wish no longer
existed but people are still getting
infected and vaccination continues to be
one of the most effective ways to
protect ourselves against serious
outcomes including severe illness
hospitalization and
death vacine protection decreases over
time which means many of us are due for
another dose receiving a shot of the new
formulation will help protect people
against the variant circulating
currently expected to ccate through the
fall and winter thank
you today I will provide an update from
the national advisory committee on
immunization on nassy on the use of Co
19 vaccines this fall and an overview of
our expectations for the upcoming
respiratory virus
season with today's authorization nassie
is reaffirming its guidance on the use
of coid 19 vaccines this fall nassie
recommends authorized age groups get an
updated coid 19 vaccine dose this fall 6
months after the last vaccine dose or
infection provinces and territories will
be providing additional information on
Co 19 and seasonal flu vaccine
availability in their respective
regions we will have enough supply of
the updated coid 19 vaccines to support
immunization programs across
Canada from the start of 2023 Co 19
indicators have been on a decline to
historically low levels for a number of
months in the last few weeks we have
started to see an increase in coid 19
indicators across many areas of the
country including
hospitalizations the Oman variant
continues to evolve with xbb subvariants
such as
.5 continuing to circulate in Canada and
globally Canada has also reported 11
cases of the Omron subvariant ba.
2.86 here's some good news preliminary
clinical data have shown promising
immune responses from the hb. one.5
vaccine the vaccine receiving regulatory
authorization today against various
Omicron Su in es including .5 and ba.
2.86 this improved immune response is
expected to better protect against the
strains that are circulating in our
communities if had if had it has been
more than 6 months since your last dose
of Co 19 vaccine or your last infection
your protection from the virus may have
waned receiving a CO 19 vaccine those
this fall with an updated formulation is
expected to increase individual
protection against infection symptoms
and severe
disease this is particularly important
for people at increased risk of severe
outcomes such as people 65 years and
older individuals with underlying
medical conditions pregnant people and
those living or working in congregate
living
settings vaccination in combination with
personal protective measures are
integral tools to reduce the negative
impact of respiratory illnesses this is
especially important as we head into the
colder months when people spend more
time indoors and the risk of respiratory
illness
increases last year Canada experienced
an early and intense influenza season
during a time of high circulation of the
respiratory citio virus or RSV putting
increased strain on already stressed
Health Care Systems particularly the
Pediatric Healthcare
System it is difficult to predict what
will happen this fall and winter
regarding the coold circulation of
influenza RSV and Co 19 given that it is
still early in the season but the good
news is we can get prepared and protect
ourselves in case simultaneous surges of
respiratory viruses
occur this is why receiving a coid 19
vaccine dose as well as a flu shot this
fall is especially important it is safe
to receive Co 19 and flu vaccines at the
same time these vaccines will help to
keep us from getting seriously ill and
by extension reduce the burden on our
health
systems treatments can also help to
reduce serious illness posed by Co
19 the government of Canada is funding
can treat coid a clinical trial with
site across Canada to evaluate
treatments like pack loid for acute coid
19 infection you can find out more more
information at can coid no sorry can
treat co.org
everyday personal protective measures
such as staying home when sick cleaning
your hands frequently properly wearing a
well-fitting mask or respirator and
improving ventilation as possible remain
effective strategies to reduce the
spread of respiratory viruses especially
when combined with
vaccination with children now back in
school check to make sure their routine
vaccines are up to date for their age
immunization Remains the number one
action we can take to protect children
from serious infectious
diseases for older adults it's important
to remember that during the four and
winter months people over the age of 65
are at greater risk for other infections
too like bacterial pneumonia so if
you're in this age group now is also a
good time to discuss getting the num
Coco vaccine with your healthc care
provider with these tools in mind I
encourage everyone to take action to
stay safe this respiratory virus season
mer thank you
me today I provide the national advisory
committe on immunization
or on the use of vaccines this fall and
an overview of our expectations for the
upcoming respiratory virus
season with's authorization the N is
reaffirming its guidance on the use of
vac this
fall recommends authorized age groups
get updated vac do this fall
mon after their
last territories will be providing
additional information on Co 19 and
seasonal flu vacine availability in
their respective
regions we will have enough supply of
the updated vacines to support
immunization programs across
Canada start of
2023 indicators have been on a deine to
historically low levels for a number of
months in the last few weeks we have
started to see an increase in Co 19
indicators across many areas of the
country including
hospitalizations VAR continues to evolve
with xbb subari such as .5 continuing to
circulate in Canada and globally Canada
has reported 11 cases of Omron
subvariant
binary clinical data have shown
promising immune responses from the
x1.5 the VAC receiving authorization
today
against
including ba
2.86 IM improved immune immune response
is expected to better protect against
the strains that we are seeing
circulating in our
communities if it has been more than six
months since your last dose of coid 19
vaccine or your last infection your
protection from the virus may
have receiving aid vaccine dose this
fall with an updated formulation is
expected increase individual protection
against infection symtoms and severe
disease
from this is particularly important for
people at increased risk of severe
illness such as people 65 years and
older individuals with underlying
medical
conditions those living or working in
congregate living
settings vaccination in combination with
personal protective measures are
integral tools to reduce the negative
impact of respiratory illness this is
especially important as we head into the
older months when people spend more time
indoors and the risk of respiratory
illness
increases year Canada experienced an
early influenza season during a time of
high circulation of RS putting increased
strain already stressed healthare system
particularly the Pediatric healthare
system it is difficult to predict what
will happen this fall and winter
regarding the co circulation of influen
RSV and Co 19 giv that given rather that
it is still early in the
season the good news is we can get
prepared and protect ourselves in case
of simultaneous surges of respiratory
viruses
occur
receiving a vac as well as a flu shot
this fall especially
important safe to receive the co 19 and
vaccines at the same time vac will help
keep us from getting seriously ill and
by extension reduce the burden on our
health
system treatment can also help to reduce
serious illness posed
by the government of is
funding a clinical trial sites across
Canada to
evaluate find more information at
can.org
everyday personal protective measures
such as staying home when cleaning your
hands
frequently wearing ating mask
and improving ventilation as much as
possible remain effective strategies to
reduce the spread of respiratory viruses
especially when combined with
vaccination children now back check to
make sure their routine vaccines are up
to date for their
age immunization Remains the number one
action we can take to protect children
from serious infectious
diseases
for older adults it's important to
remember that during the fall and winter
months people over the age of 65 are at
greater risk of other
infections bacterial
pneumonia so if you're in this age group
now is a good time to discuss numac
vaccine with your
Healthcare with these tools in mind I
encourage everyone to take action
toat
virus thank you m
witch I believe it's time for questions
um so we'll go first in questions in the
room I recognize two reporters and then
we'll go on
zoom and on Zoom you can use the raise
hand
function you like to speak start with
Mia rapson Ken
impress good morning afternoon whatever
time of day it is today um I'm just
wondering Dr Tam if you can give us some
more information on the current
situation with Co we've heard about this
uptick um how where are we at sort of in
comparatively and are the vaccines now
going to come at a time that will
actually help this fall or by the time
we actually get them get them into arms
and they take effect will it be too late
to slow whatever wave we're seeing right
now yes so right now um we have been
seeing this uptick of Co 19 uh activity
in waste water in some areas of the
country but that's a little unstable
it's gone up and then in some areas is
come down as well so um but overall uh
the coid uh indicators are still at
quite low levels and low to moderate in
some areas so we're just at the
beginning I think of uh this fall winter
uh
circulation so it's not too late to get
uh Co 19 vaccine and the flu shot even
throughout the season particularly as
we're trying to prevent serious outcomes
as
well thank you and I'm going to put a
whole bunch of questions into this one
so um are you able to get this vaccine
at the same time as the flu shot is that
something that would be recommended or
possible um do we know if they will
still be free or if some provinces are
going to have to make that decision and
also in terms of uptake the bent uptake
was relatively low compared to the
original or the primary series what are
we trying to do to overcome that and
what what do you think uh can overcome
that thank you um
so the um provinces and territories for
the most part are planning to be able to
provide both vaccines at the same time
um and so that may increase access and
uptake make it more convenient for
people so one visit to vaccinations at
the same time and as I've said in my
opening remarks marks it is safe to
provide both vaccines at the same time
as well and in in terms of uh some of
the data that we have on surveys that we
conducted on vaccine coverage as well as
um on public opinion surveys as well is
that one of the reasons for example that
people didn't say get the flu shot was
because it was kind of inconvenient for
them and they um you know didn't get
around to it was one of the um reasons
and so if we are uh essentially in the
jurisdictions trying to link up both
vaccination program uh it may just make
it a little bit easier
um and um of course um long-term care
facilities and other high-risk settings
will likely be the focus um for the
initial provincial territorial programs
just as they do with uh influenza
vaccines and I think uh Province and
territories will be providing further
information on the start dates of those
programs and so you should check in with
your local
jurisdiction uh the federal government
is continuing to uh provide the coid 19
vaccine um and
um we also providing support for um the
high does influenza vaccine for
long-term care as
well following up with the mar Dr maybe
I could just add points in terms of the
the issue of vaccine uptake so there
there's lots of things that we've
learned uh over the past three years uh
one of things that the government of
Canada is also doing is I think we're
spending up to $10 million with what we
call immunization partnership fund to
actually encourage initiatives that
would increase vaccine uptake among
maybe uh certain groups at risk that may
not to have uh uh maybe the the same
access to the vaccine as others uh We've
also learned that there's multiple ways
to to basically give Canadians the
information they need we think by and
large Canadians respect understand the
science but uh uh they need a multiple
sort of channels to be able to to get
that information so providing tools for
example to the Frontline providers such
as their family physicians uh also
reaching out to trusted leaders in the
community be it faith-based influencers
we're we're looking at sort of a
multi-prong approach rather than just
quote having a few Talking Heads here
sitting at a press conference
thanks apologies for that uh next
question is from uh Marina stackelberg
CBC hi there good afternoon you don't
have the word booster here I wanted to
know is that intentional and are you
wanting Canadians to change the way they
look at getting the coid
vaccine I think we wanted to um
emphasize this this is an updated um
coid 19
vaccine uh and similarly we update
influenza vaccines as well um and it
will increase they getting an additional
those will increase um your immunity uh
antibody levels uh and uh also increase
uh vaccine protection against serious
outcomes um yeah it's it's a matter of
terminology but I think we're trying to
standardize and simplify some of the um
various terms the moment uh I know
perhaps Dr Sharma has a take on that and
uh Dr Tunis as well yeah thank you Dr
Tam so yes there's been lots of
discussions amongst Regulators around
terminology and so there was there's an
internationally agreed upon simplified
um dosing schedule now so that's it was
we won't see the wor primary series as
much a booster and it's not quite
stabilized yet but the idea is that
we'll get to a place where it may be
much like the flu vaccines where people
may be on a regular schedule getting an
updated vaccine and so really I think
there's more benefit just talking about
the latest vaccine or the updated
vaccine rather than going back to years
ago when we were talking about your very
first two doses or um speaking about
boosters I do I don't mind the word
booster because it actually does talk
about what the vaccines additional doses
of the vaccines do for the immune system
they take it from a place where that
immunity might be waning a bit and boost
it up to a higher level so I don't mind
that terminology but again it's really
to simplify the overall dosing schedule
in the way that we talk about
it yeah I I can comment from um the the
advice we've received from
nassie um the the the committee is I
think in their statement they maybe make
mention to booster a couple of times but
generally we're seeing a transition
towards that additional dose language in
line with the regulator and the
authorized monograph and there's
discussion about those that are
previously vaccinated which we
historically would have thought of as
boosting and then those that are
previously not vaccinated so the first
dose or the the primary series and
you'll see in the regulatory materials
that there's that distinction between
previously vaccinated or previously
unvaccinated and nassi is mirroring that
in their advice and the way that the
scheduled discussions are going one
thing I'll note is that with this
authorization for madna today the nasy
advice um is updating onboarding madna
into the the recommended options for
this fall we don't have the others yet
so fizer or novax are both submitted and
under review by the regulator and they
might have slightly different schedules
as they have so far for the previously
unvaccinated or the primary Series so
nassie has been working through the
summer trying to look at all the
products um we only have one today with
madna but as the others come through we
would expect future uh updates from
nassie around what we had previously
called the primary series or you know
for someone coming new into the the
vaccine schedule who was not immunized
before can nassie provide a sort of
simplified harmonized approach across
the public health system for the
different products so they're continuing
to work on that and we'll see more
updates coming in the coming months I
think as more products are authorized
maybe with slightly different schedules
and or different nomenclature and the
committee will be onboarding that to try
make things as simple as possible
because we appreciate that the co 19
vaccine environment has um been been
complex at times and so the regulator
and nassie are both seeking to simplify
as much as possible in the language and
the
schedules thanks for that what is the
timeline here when can Canadians expect
to actually be able to go and receive
this
shot yes so with the regulatory
authorization the manufacturer in this
case madna will start mobilizing uh
vaccines to Canada and most Province and
territories are planning uh to begin the
their coid 19 programs at around the
same time as the influenza programs so
we expect they public aiming for the
beginning of October or thereabouts and
some but that will vary a little bit so
you do have to check
locally thank
you
raise hand at this point so I can
recognize you on Zoom uh first question
on Zoom is from Megan deler CV news you
have the
floor hi and good afternoon um what are
Health Canada's greatest concerns around
the latest variants detected in
Canada so this is uh Teresa Tam from the
public health agency I'll take uh the
first go at that uh question so um as
I've said in my remarks the Omron
variant these are all the subvariants of
Omron those new ones that you've been
hearing about or descendants of the
Omron um variant itself so um and that
is expected actually for a virus that's
circulating in uh or around the world
and so we're monitoring uh these viruses
quite closely uh through various means
and connecting with International
Partners so far none of the recent
subaran of Omron have demonstrated
increase um virence or
severity um I think there was just some
uh latest data coming from the United
Kingdom on the ba. 2.86 as well related
to a outbreak so so that's that's
generally good none of the recent
variants seems to uh result in more
severe outcomes but that doesn't mean
that with increase in cases you wouldn't
get an significant burden on uh the
health system or on population Health um
and um so so I think I think it is
really a matter of ongoing uh monitoring
but the other good news of course that
we've also mentioned is that we expect
the updated xb. one.5 vaccine to to
mount antibody responses uh that are
similar uh to these newest variants as
is done um against the xb. one.5 so
that's good news as
well and to add from the health
candidate sorry is that okay if I just
it's a preious Sharm if I could just add
a couple of points is that
right go ahead take that as a yes um so
I mean I guess the question of what do
you worry about when we're a health
canid is everything we're professional
worriors that's our job um but when it
comes comes to the the mutations and the
variants there's it's two fold so one is
when you see these mutations especially
when you have variants that are what we
call highly mutated the question will be
whether or not um the vaccines that we
currently have or we're reviewing or
approved would have uh Effectiveness
against those variants and as well the
tests that we have whether it's rapid
tests or other tests whether or not they
would pick up and detect those variants
so you know the concern really around um
some of the new variants was primarily
around ba point 2.86 because it was so
highly mutated um it seems that that's
it's I wouldn't say it's a nothing
Burger but it doesn't seem like it's the
one that would um dominate at this point
in time and thankfully we do have data
to show that the current vaccines that
we are reviewing and the one that we've
approved does have effect against all of
the variants that we're sort of seeing
that are that are dominating currently
same thing with the test we go to the
the manufacturers of the test to get
data on whether or not these um new
variants are able to be detected by the
uh rapid tests we're still in the
process of looking at that data and
getting that data in um and if there are
any concerns obviously we will uh we
will uh communicate that follow up
Meg thank you um and is there is there
any evidence to suggest that
um symptoms and and transmissibility uh
sorry transmissibility are are less
severe um in these latest variants than
we typically
um so according to some laboratory data
um and there you know there's not a
whole lot of them um at the moment um
the ba. 2.6 sub Varian appears to be
less able to infect cells so that's
gives us a little bit of a
clue um which is also good news but we
have to monitor that quite uh closely as
well and um I think as I said there does
not seem to be any evidence to date that
these new subvariant are causing any
different range of symptoms or increased
severity question
from to protect
yourself you're plan on
recomending are we going back to
mandatory
masks thank you for the
question Mas one of the person prot
measures that is just another level of
protection that we can comine with other
practices such as frequently washing
your hands staying
home as well as getting vaccinated get
new vaccine I think we need to combine
all of this together and that
will better place to make sure that
we're not overburdening our healthare
system saw last winter that there was a
huge
up pressure on our
syst RV and 19 and so I think this year
important that we Implement all possible
measures to prevent this so one of those
things is getting vaccinated against 19
and the flu and wearing a
mask so if I've understood
[Music]
correctly will be an individual choice
for people whether or not they want to
wear a
mask we are no longer mandating that
people wear
masks now individual
Choice protect themselves who who are
more susceptible
to right now we have hyrid
immunity either been vaccinated or have
had 19 or both and so I would say that
now the situation is different
it is like I said a good personal
protective
measure and I think it's important that
Canadians see that it's not just a
personal prot meure but it's also a way
to protect other
people Tak care of
each and thinking about our communities
and those in Canada are accept to
becoming seriously ill those with lower
IM systems for example under medical
conditions and so mask wearing is a
decision that can be made for yourself
but also for others next up T right I
politics hi there um my question is for
Dr Tam um less than six% of Canadians
have received a booster in the last um
six months according to the latest data
online How concerned are you about
Canadian protection against coid
19 so um we're in a very different
situation than we were of course during
the early moments of the pandemic based
on some of the studies have been
conducted um we know that um really
close to 80% of people in this country
certainly in the adult population may
have already um got infected particular
in the post Omron era on top of having
had
two um of the initial doses quite a high
vacine coverage we know immunity does uh
decrease with time so I think part of
the reasons that we think there's an
increase in uptick right now is this
reduce immunity over time which is why
there's a recommendation to get uh the
updated vaccine if it's been 6 months
since uh your last infection or
vaccination I think the spring booster
we have always felt that that's probably
going to not be the highest uptake by
that time I think uh it's really the
people at the highest risk who was most
interested in getting an additional dose
um activity was coming down at that time
as well so but for this uh upcoming
respiratory virus season we anticipated
that there's a lightly increase that
we're going to see which was just
beginning uh at this point together with
the other respiratory viruses so we are
absolutely encouraging people to get
protected uh both with Co 19 vaccine and
the flu shot um prior to um the um
period ahead and so but we'll still be
monitoring the effectiveness of these
vaccines over the season and nassie will
keep a close eye on uh if necessary for
the uh vaccine
recommendations and just as a followup
um you know you talked about earlier
about um getting uh prepared ahead of
the flu season um but here it is mid
September schools already started um for
you know for some time now and we
haven't been hearing from public health
officials like yourselves um you know
you know in quite some time um I'm
wondering why we haven't been getting
more regular updates on whether it's you
know updated advice on on vaccines or on
the newest variants and whether the
reason that we're not hearing more is
because of concerns about political
backlash well I think uh we haven't been
doing a lot of press conferences uh but
we're providing data uh on an ongoing
basis on our website for instance uh and
doing uh individual interviews as needed
uh but we have been uh having
really historically low levels of uh Co
19 activity and the first time we've
seen that really um since the start of
the pandemic during uh from from January
uh until more recently I think this is a
really opportune moment to make sure
that we uh come out with our key
messages because of the authorization of
the updated vaccine as well as Province
and territories are beginning to Gear Up
for the um flu and coid 19
vaccinations so I think um you know
we're glad to be here and um answering
your questions at this time I think flu
vaccine programs um have generally in in
Province and territory start in October
uh people usually get vaccinated between
October and November time frame we have
a fairly long fall winter season of
course in Canada and you can still get
viruses and viral activities uh like
influenza until April so um again it's
never too late uh to get your
vaccines
question microphone
is
microphone
for the question this is Dr
from I think we're in a better situation
today compared to at the beginning of
the
pandemic as we can see
H situation and we
for we have a lot of tools we know more
about protective me that are very
effective weing Mas like I said
a but it is a personal
choice people will
realize English we talk about the
three different acronym
in we're talking about
cles close
cont certain
situations as contact
SP it is a good idea to wear mask and
then also if working with people who are
higher
risk I do know that in certain spes
Hospital
I was speak with colle another Province
I was told
that the the
hospital everyone who comes
hosital for those who manage B such as
hospitals andar
a good
idea and I think that everyone is able
to take these different factors into
account to make a good
[Music]
decision would you be able to
question
throughout the last years the pandemic
the government of
Canada provided free vac for provinces
and
territories if we look at what happened
in in a
in in
situ and territories are
[Music]
responsible manage buk
procur we are the ones who are able to
make
think this is something that we can
follow up on F this is not just for vac
for all V and medication that is
distributed throughout the provinces
Mercy thank you I noticed there are two
reporters from city news that request to
ask questions so I don't know if it's a
mistake but I'll start up with uh oh
okay that this
Exel from city news please go
ahead hi right thanks for taking my
question um so I wanted to ask about
rapid tests given that much of what was
already in Canadian inventory has
expired and given the expected next wave
is Canada going to be purchasing more
rapid tests for distribution to
provinces or is there going to be
guidance on use of expired tests what's
the plan
here
so the federal government uh still has
uh rapid test in uh the stop pile
basically but uh hasn't been uh has
stopped sending out any rapid tests to
provin
territories uh upon discussion with them
because they feel that they have what
they needed um and in general uh is not
really appropriate to use expired test
I'm looking at the regular
all I would say is if you if you use any
rapid tests just a reminder that if it's
negative it may not mean you you don't
have coid uh the key is to probably do
serial testing if you think you have
coid and you get a negative test if you
get a positive test it's likely that you
have coid and you can take uh the
necessary
precautions um but uh there's no
specific plans to purchase more from the
federal government at this point in time
and just to add to that with respect to
the expiry dates for the tests so
basically the expiry dates are based on
the data that were submitted at the time
that those tests were authorized if the
company has additional data to show that
they could be used beyond that date and
they'll provide that to health Canada we
will review that and if that then gets
extended um we'll have a new expiry date
for those products and all of those lots
and the names of the devices and the
tests are all in the health a website so
you can check which ones have been
extended and what the current expiry
dates are and if they've been uh um
Extended to what
date uh thanks for that just as a
followup and S to C off but I just
wanted to take note you're all you're
all masking which is lovely to see of
course but most government ministers are
are not now most MPS are not most people
on the street are not masking is is
there any specific guidance on that
going forward at at this
point
yes Teresa Tam so um it is a lay of
protection we hope people have developed
the Habit to be able to use mask as
needed during the respiratory virus
season not just for Co for all the other
um respiratory pathogens that will be
transmitted around this time so I do
think now is the time to get your masks
ready if you don't already have them um
in our own particular context we
certainly in our area there's been an
uptake in some of the coid 19 indicators
uh for me personally there there have
been cases around um you know even my
work colleagues so uh that's one of the
reasons uh why we are wearing masks
today mer thank you I see no more
questions on
Zoom as a moderator if you would allow
me I'd like to finish with one quick
question over the last
years it December
that years that we've
had and there have been a lot
of now that we
have I would like to know if this rmna
technology has
death amongst those who have received
this type of vaccine in the last three
years hundreds millions of doses of
this
we stud side effects of this generally
we can say that these vaccines are
extremely safe
and and it was a miracle that we were
able to develop
this and so these V used very
well I can say this based off of our
what we' seen today I'm happy to see the
work that we've done with these vacines
and I hope that in the future we will be
able to continue using this type of mRNA
technology Dr and now I will give the
floor to my colleague
Dr so in terms of
vac said this is technology that we've
been using for several
years now this technology was developed
about a decade AG in relation to cancer
medication but for the general
population it is
new what we've seen
with allows us to increase
immunity and it's actually easy
toce
we can see today that this is a very
flexible typ
technology we seen that we're able
therefore to adap vacines
forward and adapt them to pathogens that
are
also in terms of
safety
heart
related relation to this
vac this is related to vaccines or
related is it zero
risk these typ of Therapies medications
vaccines there is
C have a lot of information a lot of
clinical testing has been
done and we have so much evidence that
shows the benefits of these vaccines
that outweigh these very rare risks that
can
when people make decision take a vacine
they have to
take of course any
heal
asso but given all the experience that
we have with this all the data that we
have I don't think there's a single
medication well studed
as and all the data that we're basing
this off of is and accessible cans you
can
look instances of side effects and how
common they are and you can see that
these are very very low levels zero but
you know as far as you're aware we have
zero confirmed cases of death associated
with
that we've been doing making that link
between a death and mRNA and a vac is
very difficult to
do
Tak to
establish
serious risk
associated it's much more likely that
death Ur because of and not the
VAC based upon the data that we have
risk confence thank you very much one
more go ahead Mia I just uh wanted to
follow up I'm just wondering why we're
not recommending two doses for people
over five who haven't been primarily
vaccinated before and if we're that
means we're completely done with the
original series or
not yeah so I mean for the authorization
the reason that it's the only the one
dose is that's the that's how it was
studied so that's what the clinical the
trials were supporting is that in
somebody that had had um they basically
looked at well there's mice models but
also the clinical studies if somebody
had had the booster Doses and then they
would look at the response as well and
then there's some studies in terms of
the overall sort of response um so we
moved away as we said from the primary
series it doesn't mean that you would
you would be one and done if you if
you've never been vaccinated but we also
have you know the majority of people
that have been infected as well so it's
a combination of you know potentially
there's a very high rate of people that
would already have some um hybrid
immunity so one dose likely is
sufficient and then we'll see will will
happen as we go um into the future and
if we do need uh regular updates um
updated vaccines after
that everything that puts an end for
real to this press conference thank you
very much for
all